uh hello everyone uh welcome to
uh uh julia our first uh first approach
uh to contributing organized by the
tribal
my name is i will be the host
of the talk today uh so
i i hope you will have a nice time with
us
uh so as you might know julia has become
quickly the preferred language for data
analytics
uh this is the first uh
talk uh about uh julian language we are
very excited about that
and to make it more switch that we have
with us uh
on one of the creator of uh julia
language
back in 2009 uh welcome uh
very odd uh we are thank you for
accepting our invitation
thank you i'm glad to be here
as i said is one of the developers of
julia language
he is now co-founder and ceo
of junior computing um since uh you know
i couldn't sort of fully hear you i
think i'm just going to get started uh
because it seems like you have some
internet
connection issues but thank you for the
the wonderful introduction
um my suggestion is uh
you know if uh if anyone has questions
please feel free to stop me and ask
i have sort of a basic presentation and
then i i will sort of be able to do a
quick hands-on demo
and uh i you know my roughly sort of
speaking time is about
30 to 45 minutes maybe so there should
be ample time for questions
um maybe since you know we have a
reasonably small group i request the
participants to
you know maybe say a little bit about
what their background is and
uh what languages are they using
um so just just so so that you know we
we know uh
you know who's using what and then i can
sort of uh
tailor my presentation towards what
people might be interested in
in hearing about but let me get started
and please feel free to interrupt me
um i will not be watching the chat as i
speak so maybe either hustle or yes mean
if you guys can interrupt me
that would be great sure okay
so why did we create the julia language
to start with right that's always the
first question that why create a new
programming language
and you know the you know there are four
of us who created julia
uh jeff bezanson stefan karpinsky
professor alan edelman
uh and myself and uh
you know so so for example my my
colleague jeff bezanson he's a you know
he's a he's a
he's a professional language designer he
just likes to design languages day in
and day out
but i am not i'm not a language designer
by trade
um you know i like to actually work on
building computational science
scientific systems
and sort of using um you know
applied mathematics and scientific
computing to solve some of the most
challenging problems that
that we face today um you know globally
right like whether it's climate change
or the pandemic
or or just about anything else right
computation has a big role to play in
solving the world's problems
and that's what i see sort of my role as
being
i but but because of you know my
collaboration with my co-founders
um we ended up sort of taking a language
approach
to solving some of these computational
problems uh
that you know that are the center of
solving some of the largest challenges
in the world
and we ended up sort of starting with
asking the question about what's broken
in the world today right
but today was 10 years ago when we
started the julia language
um and what was broken was
that we had the two language problems
right python sas
our matlab these were all the languages
is that people wanted to write in that
the experts the domain you know the data
scientists
the engineers um your physical
scientists the biologists
you know anyone who's a domain
specialist was working with algorithms
was writing and you know in this
high level abstract environment however
when these ideas need to be scaled up to
large data sets need to be put into
production
that need to be done on thousands of
servers or on a supercomputer you have
to rewrite these
same uh high-level abstract algorithms
in c plus plus or c sharp or java so
effectively you're writing the same
program twice and this was a huge
barrier to innovation this was a huge
barrier
to get those ideas out into the real
world
and this is why we started the julia
language we we thought that what is most
broken in the world
is that science needs its own language
and and i like to think about the
language of science
um and now we have sort of you know this
was what we started out with 2009
in 2012 we released the first version of
julia
and now in 2020 2018 we released julia
1.0 so it's now a stable language
and now in 2020 we have released julia
1.5 and what we really have
is not just a technical platform which
is you know where programmers and data
scientists and scientists and engineers
and biologists and all these people
statisticians
financial quants you know since you guys
are from saudi arabia i mean maybe i
should also point out uh you know oil
and gas right that's a big industry
uh where julia is a big part of um
and all these people are you know now
collaborating
in the same language and the language is
julia right so
so the the computer scientists and the
domain specialists are all talking the
same language
and so julia has not just brought about
a technical unification
but also a social unification that when
people are using the same programming
language
they're collaborating with the same set
of tools and they can start talking to
each other
and this is where we think that the
innovation cycles
are really compressed by something like
julia
and as i go along you'll see you know
how
you know this achieves some of what i
sort of you know talked about
uh something um how how julia
being the language of science helps
solve some of the most difficult
scientific problems the world faces
today
now i'm going to sort of start out with
something much simpler
what is julia right and and i'm going to
start off with some benchmarks um
this would be a good time for me to sort
of know um
if uh people have uh you know said
anything about the programming languages
that they use
so i'm just gonna quickly pop over to my
chat window here can
can you guys also see the chat window i
guess
more sas here python um
there's a statistician maybe not
programming uh more like a
okay we have someone doing c plus and
python
and uh
matlab as well okay so even in this
relatively uh you know small group of
people who've answered these questions
right um sorry
uh we have you know like about five or
six people have answered
and you see already such a large
collection of languages but
interestingly almost everyone is using
more than one
all right so if you're coming from one
of these languages you'd be wondering
you know what does julia what is it
for me if i have to you know if i sort
of uh incorporate julia into my
set of languages and the first example i
have
is from the computer language benchmark
scheme if you just google that phrase
you will find uh you'll find what
you know you'll find these benchmarks
it's actually a collection of 12 or 15
maybe about a dozen problems and they're
they've been sort of
programmed in all these different
languages and this is only the set of
languages that fits on their
you know first chart there are many
others so if you notice
python does not even make it onto this
one matlab does not make it r does not
make it here
um in fact the only
dynamically typed language that makes it
here
is julia and all these others are
largely statically typed languages
and everyone else is much further out
and these are
sorted by ratios right so comparing your
performance with c
so if you're low low down here close to
this value one that means you're as fast
as c
and julia is very close to one right
it's between one and three it's actually
like a factor of 1.5
and um this is uh this is an older
version of julia benchmarks i believe
multi-threading has not yet been enabled
in julia
for these benchmarks so julia would come
even lower down in my opinion
um out here but you know python for
example would be sort of in the 30 to 50
range
sas would be up there i think all the
dynamic languages would be way up there
in performance
about anywhere between 20 to 50 times
slower than julia
all right so then you know over the
years many interesting new uh benchmarks
have come up
there's a graph processing benchmark in
julia uh that that someone put out by
comparing julia python
you know so like graphs is julia i think
network
uh network kit is python and then some
of these others are probably c
plus plus based and julia is about 100
times faster than python in this one
similarly here's a k-means clustering
algorithm and julia is 100x faster there
or scikit-learn um here are some data
frames benchmarks that were put together
by h2o.ai
it's a machine learning company and
they're comparing spark julia python
pandas are everything and julia turns
out to be
over two times faster on group by
operations
compared to many of the other competing
systems um so let's see pandas
is 92 seconds here julia
is dataframes.jl right so 42 seconds
and then d player is 191 seconds versus
42.
so and then these implementations in r
and python are actually done under the
hood in c plus right so julia
is actually showing you the true power
of what it means when you have a high
performance language
and the right kinds of abstractions and
primitives here's another
very simple benchmark loading csv files
and it turns out that across a variety
of these benchmarks julia can be
anywhere from you know as fast as the
existing things to 30 times faster
just for loading uh csv files
um in fact in python we are comparing
with pandas in our comparing with
i believe with f read but r is able to
go multi-threaded python is not
um at the moment i think or rather
pandas is not
um and julia is able to leverage
multiple strengths as well
now one of the things that people love
about julia and i always say this the
people always come for the performance
but stay for the experience right so
performance is what i talked about
before
experience is what i have on on this
slide right and this is just one small
part of the julia experience but
for example julia has a completely
well specified set of version
dependencies
that can be uh specified either at the
project level or
in a manifest um a project defines your
dependencies so you know i'm going to
use
this and this version of the you know
this other package
and so on and so forth whereas a
manifest is a complete
encapsulation of the state of a program
about every single dependency and which
version of that dependency was used
so what ends up happening is the julius
package manager
and the compute ecosystem are set up in
such a way that you know let's say if
you fast forward five years from now
in a very clear way you will be able to
regenerate the state of
you know all your programs and
dependencies that were used to reproduce
the results
and julia gives you this level of
reproducibility that is simply not
available in any other system
in my opinion excuse me
however one of the most interesting
things about julia is its
ability to use multiple dispatch so many
of you would be familiar with
object oriented programming julia is a
multiple dispatch system so think about
it as a generalization of object
oriented programming but something that
has come
from the world of functional programming
and here's an example of two very
separate packages
different packages differential
equations and measurements differential
equations
is what you know this you know it's it's
all the differential equation
measurements is something that
introduces errors uh you know that that
allows you to
well does not introduce errors in your
program but introduces the concept of
uh propagating errors through your
computations so for example if
years you know everyone knows that the
motion of a pendulum right if you plot
it
it's a sine wave and uh
you know if you're going to simulate the
pendulum you have the value of the
gravitational constant the length of the
pendulum pendulum
the initial um speed and angle and time
span and so on and so forth and
and then you put these things together
and then you pass it to the solver
however the ode solver was only used
written to work with double precision
numbers
um but then we sort of you know have
this amazing measurements package that
came along
and you know the idea is very
straightforward that you know the
gravitational constant is 9.79 meters
per second square
but maybe we do not know it accurately
so maybe it is plus or minus
you know 0.02 right it may be either
9.77 or maybe 9.81
and similarly the length of the pendulum
and all these other measurements may
have some uncertainty in them
so it turns out that if we just you know
if we just use
um if you just use these perfect values
the solver will give you the perfect
answer which would be the sine curve
but now if instead of um the perfect
values you pass in these values right
with with uh uncertainty bounds or error
bounds
then the plot that you get is the sine
curve but you also get uncertainty as
well
on it right so this is this is uh
you know this is what ends up happening
uh in julia so these are two separate
packages
but because of the power of multiple
dispatch they were able to integrate in
way
in a way that was simply not possible in
other systems
a lot of people wonder who's using julia
right like is it just this thing out of
mit or is it just a small open source
project there are over
10 000 companies that we know about that
are using julia
and if you go to juliacomputing.com you
can see a lot of the commercial case
studies
and i'll come back to these in a little
bit
a lot of universities are teaching julia
as well so
you know these are some of the
universities that are already teaching
julia but
you know this is again a small
collection there are um
there are at least 1500 universities
from where we see julia downloads
um
this on the left hand side here is
programming language rankings right so
julia rank
number 19 on the ieee spectrum rankings
that just came out a couple of months
ago
um it's i think it's phenomenal for a
language like julia to be ranked
at this high this soon and it has been
growing very steadily over the years
um the nature magazine which is you know
one of the most premier scientific
magazines
had a beautiful article on julia last
year with this title come for the syntax
stay for the speed a lot of books
available on julia if you
fancy yourself as someone who wants to
use books uh to learn julia and many of
these are actually
textbooks teaching you advanced
algorithms and
mathematics using julia as a language
whereas you know a book like think julia
teaches you julia itself
um there are many more language many
more books available now and i will show
you a complete list on the julia website
shortly
all right um i think at this point i
want to
you know before i jump into the ai part
of my presentation i'd like to maybe
show a little bit of the code and the
syntax
and and also the julia website so let me
first give you a quick tour of
some of the things i mentioned in my
presentation
oops oh by the way we just had our julia
con
2020 uh this you know was supposed to
happen in lisbon in portugal this year
however
because of the pandemic it went it ended
up being completely online
and we had you know typically in a
conference here we have 300 uh people
who joined the conference
in person however this year we had 26
000 people who stopped by our youtube
channel
um and all the videos are are recorded
and available in the youtube playlist
out here so you should be able to you
know watch all of these
or if you prefer to sort of go through
the agenda itself
we have a schedule and and you could
actually look at all the talks
you know that happen on each year
that's like on each day of the
conference and then you can click
through and
and watch them uh it was uh it was it
was a fantastic conference and
uh there were 164 talks this year so i
would i would highly recommend you to
go to this website and watch that all
right
um here's the julia language website
so this is you know if you're beginning
the purpose of my talk here right now is
not to teach you julia as much as to
teach you how to navigate the world of
julia
so that you know you can easily download
it set it up try it out and get going
so here's our landing page you know
here's what it's used for
the videos all that good stuff uh
packages
um blog posts but the one i wanted to
show you was that julia has all the
editors and tooling and ids that you
would like to use
um you know and and the one that i have
open right here in the background that i
will switch to very quickly is bs code
so julia has a fantastic vs4 plug-in and
i'll come back to that later
many of you might have heard of the
jupiter notebooks so jupiter
is i don't know how many of you knew
this but jupiter actually stands for
julia python and r
so julia is actually the ju in jupiter
all right um oh this list has expanded
since i saw it last but julia is very
very
you know well positioned on uh on social
media so
you know feel free to engage with us in
all these places
the thing i wanted to show you was if
you go to the download page you get
you know this is you this is where you
download julia from
this is the official release from julia
community
and it's available on all the three
major operating systems
we have fantastic documentation so if
you go to docs.julialang.org
you can get on you can just just
immediately get access to all of this
um we have a fantastic blog
so feel free to sort of go through it
you can also see the first
blog post on why we created julia here
this is what sort of kickstarted the
whole project and made it open source in
2012.
um lots of community options we have a
fantastic
discourse and cha discourse and slack
i would you know if you're seriously
interested in julia
i would highly encourage you to join the
julia slack channel
and also join the julia discourse forum
which is more of a mailing list format
the best way to learn julia is julia
academy so this is
a free website that is run by the julia
community which has lots of courses
on on learning julia on how to use julia
for data science
on on modeling application on
applications for the pandemic modeling
um data frames foundations of machine
learning
deep learning parallel computing and so
on and so forth
so um so here's for example the machine
learning course and here's you know so
you can just basically pick up how to
work with data
linear algebra statistics clustering
classification graphs
numerical optimization everything just
sort of in one place
um and buddha nasr is is one of the
you know most uh prominent julia
contributors
and and researchers so it's a beautiful
course and i would love you to
try it out um apart from that i
mentioned these books and classrooms but
there are more
books so this is the complete list of
all books available in julia
and so on and so forth
i wanted to quickly draw your attention
to julia computing so julia computing
provides a commercial distribution of
julia called julia pro and then
a set of products uh julia team which is
which is for running julia in the
enterprise in your company
and julia on the cloud through julia run
and i'll just speak a little bit more
about these as we go along
um the thing i wanted to demonstrate is
that a lot of times when users come to
julia
they want to know about who's using
julia which companies are using julia
can i get a job if i was using julia
right
i really love julia but i just want to
sort of
you know make sure that i have not heard
about enough companies using it
so we have so a lot of case studies from
pharma companies aerospace companies
banking
insurance finance um energy companies
all uh you know conservation researchers
just so many amazing case studies um
this one is one of my favorites the zip
lines
drone delivery where you know this drone
is used in rwanda to deliver
blood um by uh
by flying this drone uh about 80
kilometers i think 40 kilometers
uh at a distance of 40 kilometers so
it's just fantastic this entire drone
design has been done in julia itself
and there's a docker juliacon for it
okay so so these are some of the case
studies for those of you who would like
to
you know know more about the use of
julia in in the enterprise
okay
all right so now i i would like to pause
and take maybe a couple of questions if
there are any
i don't think there are any questions
yet but
feel free to ask before i jump into a
demo
okay so here's vs code i have loaded uh
julia in here
and uh you know if you google julia and
yeah oh sorry you don't even need to
google anything if you go to
juilliardlang.org
you can go all the way down and click on
this ds code icon
and it will tell you how to install
julia on vs code
okay so so this is this is the i
this is the website for that
when you install it this is what it's
going to look like um i have my julia
program here
i have my terminal here and then i have
this extra pain here called julia hub
which is which is a product
of julia computing but i personally love
to have it open because
every time i run a small compute in my
system if i want to scale it up i just
have sort of you know the number of
cores and i can just start my job and
run it on the cloud
but this is a separate plugin you may or
may not like to have it installed i
personally
always just keep it on nowadays
all right um so here's what the syntax
looks like
so let's maybe try to make it a little
bigger here
and this is just a computing pi so
here's your function
here's a for loop in julia just fairly
straightforward
and here's how you write an if statement
and here's how you do timings in julia
the easy way
so what i'm doing is generating a random
number
in the for loop uh a million times and
then i'm checking if it lands in this
you know uh if i if it lands in the
circle or it lands outside the circle
so if you know the uh a terrible way to
estimate pi but a very simple way is to
throw these random darts on a square
which has a circle inside of it
and the ratio gives you you know it's a
monte carlo algorithm
so the ratio gives you sort of an
estimate of the value of pi
so if i go and press shift enter here
now
it's actually going to run this program
so let me clear my screen
and do this again okay so if i run this
program
it ran in 0.009 seconds oops
and it estimated the value of pi to be
3.13
and and i tried it again and it came out
as 3.14
the thing i'd like to point out is that
in python you would never
ever do such a thing right or in r you
would never do such a thing i'm pretty
sure you would never do this thing in
sas as well
you would never write a for loop that
goes from one to one million
it is just never going to finish i mean
it will finish but it will finish in a
long time
whereas if you wrote this in c it would
roughly take about the same amount of
time
and this is what this is where julia
really shines right so
it is interactive just like you know
python matlab r
sas all of these systems but it gives
you the performance of c
plus and you know we can actually go and
look look at the code
um of this thing uh let's see so
you know i can actually look at the
assembly code that was generated
for this function and you know i may not
want to read all this stuff
but you know if i'm if i'm a certain
kind of programmer who cares about
performance
i might want to sort of take a poke at
it and just make sure that it's doing
all the right things
under the hood right but you know this
is what julia does right it is a
compiler it's not an interpreter and
because of the language design and the
way the compiler works we are able to
get significant amounts of performance
uh sorry viral we have a question ah
okay
does julia use gpus by default
that's a great question juliet julia is
completely able to use gpus
um in fact let me go to another website
in the juilliard world called julia
hub.com
um so here's the this is all
you know so julia has a website front
end which shows you everything about
every package
and julia has a gpu compiler it's called
cuda.jl
so this is the package right here and
julia is the only other language i
believe after c
plus plus that actually has native gpu
code generation capabilities so you can
actually run
a gpu program in julia completely
natively without learning c
plus plus or cuda or any of those things
and that is enabled by this
jl package in fact you can look at all
the packages that
in julia in the julia world that use
cuda and there are so many different
machine learning models differential
equations solvers physics
solvers statistical programming systems
just so many different things
reinforcement learning systems that are
all using julia
julia's gpu support
i see another question here what about
analyzing arabic text
using julia are there some models or
libraries
you know there is a there is a package
in julia for working with
nlp it's called text analysis and it
does quite well
julia itself is not restricted to the
ascai
system so julia actually uses full
unicode it's completely unicode
throughout
all all along and i believe as a result
it should be straight
you shouldn't have to sort of do
anything special to work with arabic
texts
the question is whether this text
analysis package itself
can work with arabic text or not i i do
not know i think someone should try it
out
and and let us know how it goes my i
suspect that many of the nlp systems out
there are probably
english specific but i'm not an expert
to be able to know the answer to it
however julia itself can do everything
so i'm going to show you uh greek
alphabets just because they show up a
lot in mathematics
and so for example i can go alpha and go
alpha equals 1.0 and beta equals
2.0 and then i can go you know
alpha plus beta
and i get that i wonder is is there a
way for me to type an arabic symbol
i don't know how to type it on my
keyboard but is there a way for me to
maybe find one online and paste it in
just just for fun
if i just go and type arabic symbols
here
um oh i need to be able to actually
copy and paste it don't mind me fumbling
around
um
right what is this it's not arabic um
let me write something in the chat
and you can copy it okay that's even
better
give me a give me something that would
be like a variable name or something
like a name yeah
okay
maybe let me just see if i can even
i just picked this random character i
don't know what i picked but uh
you know it works right you can see but
uh i'll i'll do what yasmine
gives me all right so what is this
it's like a hello or welcome something
like that
okay but i don't know if i can have uh
spaces in it right
you want it without spaces like just the
first word
okay let me do it this way let me do it
this way hold on um i'll just make it a
string how about that
okay i can do this and i can go
x equals this how about that and then i
can go print ln of x
and so it printed it right can you just
um zoom in so we can see
ah okay is this
a little better should i zoom in one
more yes yes great
right so you know this is i i assign
this to x
and i could ask type of x
and it's a string so julia strings you
know
are by default unicode strings and uh
and then i was able to print it and you
know i can sort of do everything with it
oh i have i'm wondering if i can even
use this variable name
now let's see
so if i say alpha equals
i suspect i don't have the right fonts
installed right because it's not
rendering them nice in my ds code
yeah sorry it has to be right to left i
i don't know how the right to left works
in a programming language system but
i'm assuming that you guys are watching
me do this and you know what you would
have to do if you were to use this
uh on your own however
julia itself is fully unicode
specific so it is uh
you know it it can it can do all these
things
um another question viral is it possible
to use our packages in julia
oh yes that's a great question so it is
absolutely possible to use our packages
in julia
and as always go to hub search packages
and you go and look for our call
call our from julia so there you go
here's ggplot from julia
right there and similarly
you can have pie call that we'll call
python from julia as well
but actually python may i might be able
to i don't have r installed on my system
but i probably do have python installed
so let me give you a little bit of a
tool for how to install a new package so
i
i enter the package mode by typing right
bracket here so i ended up
in my pkg mode here and now i'm adding
pi call
so now you know i haven't installed the
pi call package in julia 1.5 because
julia 1.5 the release just happened last
week
and so i have not added pi call to this
version so what is happening now is that
julia is updating its list of packages
there are about 4
000 packages available in the julia
ecosystem already
but then julia can also call any python
or our package
oh maybe i'm going to not like the fact
that i did this because now it's
installing honda and damage
apologies i don't know what i should do
here maybe i'll open up a new terminal
i'm just gonna kill it sorry i don't
want to wait for installing conda
on this car you know it might take a few
minutes so
um there is a way to not install conda
let me just see if i can figure it out
how do i use a system python
just give me a second
aha i can just say enb python okay so
i'm gonna say env
python so if i set this environment
variable
oops if i said this environment variable
equals
slash user slash pins python
then i suspect that
um i should be able to install this
okay so if i now go using python
so the first time you use the julia
package you have to pre-compile it this
happens only for the first time and
sometimes it can take a little bit of
time
if it's a very complex package i think
fight call is not too complex so it will
be ready to use very quickly
and now that i have pycal going for
example we can pick some examples from
here
and go using python we already did that
so
we are going to pi import you know the
math module
so you can see it's kind of found where
my math module is in my python on my mac
right here and then i can just go ahead
and call
sine of pi in python so that's
that's actually calling the python sine
and the python pi
and we can subtract it from the julia
version
of course in julia we will use the
unicode price for the real five
and there we go it turns out they give
the same answers
um but you can do a lot more right you
can you can import matplotlib
and you can you know use it for plotting
you can do all sorts of things so it's a
fairly comprehensive
uh set of capabilities
okay um
so here's so yeah so this was a little
bit of a demo so let's get back now
so you know this is this is a very quick
uh demo of the julia syntax and the id
and you know the tooling and everything
and
you know this is what it is
let's go back to presentation
so i want to switch a little bit to the
ai part of my presentation and why is
julia a good language for ai i
and hopefully you've seen that our focus
on performance our focus on gpus our
focus on doing all these amazing things
with julia makes it a very good language
for doing high performance computing
and that makes it a natural system for
machine learning
and you know everyone has been talking
about deep learning all this time
and you know your standard sort of
image processing algorithms
are the ones that have been most popular
or natural language algorithms
nlp models that do nlp models that do
computer vision models that do
speech synthesis these have been amazing
solutions that have come out from the
world of deep learning
and a lot of that has been enabled by
two things right the ability to run on
gpus and automatic differentiation right
the ability to take a derivative
of your program is what is essential to
making
uh the modern deep learning frameworks
work
so we asked ourselves the question you
know what if you could you know not just
do
a differentiable program sorry what you
know what
it's a field that we call differentiable
programming but what if you could do
automatic differentiation of
more than just the deep learning models
that you've written
um you know in tensorflow or pytorch
right what if we could generalize this
to any julia program
you could then take a derivative of any
julia program put it in an optimization
loop
and solve many new classes of problems
that
current frameworks are not well suited
to solve and this is what andrei
karpathi referred to as the software 2.0
revolution
about how you know we'll be able to you
know have computational resources that
are disposable to search the space for a
program that works as opposed to write a
program from scratch
and chris latner when he was at google
articulated
this very well about how you know
differentiable programming can only be
enabled
through a language level effort and he
identified julia and swift as the two
systems that were well suited for doing
this sort of thing
we had a you know famous tweet from jeff
dean about julia running on
not just gpus but this was about tpus
and
uh and and this was this was fantastic a
lot of people
took recognition of it so julia today
has a very rich eco
system the thing that makes julia
amazing uh for ai
uh and machine learning is that
not only do we have all the usual
algorithms and not only can we recall
all the r and python machine learning
packages
but you can incorporate the rich
libraries the rich set of julia packages
in your
deep learning ecosystem in your deep
learning algorithms that you might be
writing on your own
so for example chris rakakus who's the
author of the differential equations
package right here
is you know used these capabilities of
julia to build a scientific machine
learning um a set of packages for
scientific machine learning
uh the likes of which are simply not
available in any other language today
um or the author of alphazero.jl
jonathan
um you know wrote
so the julia implementation of alpha
zero is only
a few hundred lines of code you can
actually read the code understand it
and start playing around with it and you
know there is no other comparably high
performance version available in an easy
to use language
so i would love to just demonstrate a
very quick
talk about alpha 0 here
um so actually i'm going to skip this
slide and just go to the next one
well everyone's interested in alpha oh
oh well
you know i think you can't find the
video or something
let's see if i can get back to my
presentation here
apologies i don't know what happened
there
uh the package i was referring to was
alpha 0.jl so you can find it right here
this is the package and uh and what i
wanted to show was
julia's you know capability of doing gpu
and parallel computing
is is just so simple right that
once you write your program it's very
easy to make it parallel whether it's
multi-threaded or distributed
or whether if you want to use gpus or a
combination of all of the above
and what i was going to show you was
this video uh which is not loading in my
slides so i'm going to just sort of
quickly
pop in here and and demonstrate it to
you
oh boy okay
sorry one more one more try here to find
this video
the easiest way to find it is the
juilliard computing sponsor talk
at 2020
and that's my video i'm not going to
show you this whole video but for being
a part of this and thanks for
all of the participants speakers we at
julia computing
are just thrilled to just give me a
second okay
so i'm gonna go full screen so please
bear with me for
this demonstration of parallelism in
julia using alpha zero
okay mine's learning and search to solve
complex and
arbitrary problems it started from the
game
which is this crazy game with so many
complex trees
and and things to to search through and
and uh alpha zero solves this by leaning
heavily on
compute and in julia we are so fortunate
to have
great contributors to the ecosystem like
jonathan laurent who we've been working
with for the past
two weeks to help deploy alphazero on
the cloud
and alphazero.jl is his package that
takes the work and and makes it simple
extensible and fast and kind of is a
awesome learning platform to understand
how alpha zero works and it's extensible
using julia's great generic interfaces
to allow you to play with new games you
can see in the logo there
it's not just for go anymore there's
chess tic-tac-toe we'll be demonstrating
uh connect four and of course since it's
all leaning
on julia uh it's understandable well
documented and
fast between one to two orders of
magnitude faster than any other high
level alternative
traditionally alpha zero implementations
have been written in c
plus or c or other hard languages and
very tied to their distributed
you know coding code mechanisms because
you have to do a lot of compute to get
an agent trained up
uh well alpha zero uses all of julia's
great parallelism tools
including distributed multi-threading
and gpu parallelism
to get the most out of all of your
things
so you can run this today on on your
desktop computers
uh and it'll take about 12 hours or more
to train
a good connect for game player
and we want to show this and get this
parallelized on the cloud so
let's look at what that looks like here
we have julia hub
in an internal release that has the the
run
on cloud functionality for up and
running uh you can see i can add
jonathan lawrence package here and a
running cloud button appears
i can click that you can see it already
knows the project and manifest so it
knows exactly what code to
to send out to all the workers i can
additionally tweak parameters right here
in the web ui or i can
select a particular branch to run off of
i have all the parameters coded up the
way i want them to be
on a particular branch here so i'll
choose those now here comes the fun part
you can
co pick your cluster uh to your heart's
content here
how many nodes how many threads what you
want to use
in this case we want to use gpu nodes
right so we can pick a
beefy gpu to use grab
11 nodes and hit start while that's
starting i can point out some other
things here you know we have some
time or cost limits to make sure you
don't go over budget
as you submit your jobs and there you go
you can see that we've successfully
submitted our job
now we'll appear down in this bottom
table where you can
see exactly what we ran what our inputs
are you can have a place for outputs or
you can even just
watch the logs roll in live and see them
start coming through this is a little
abridged
because i only have five minutes uh but
you can see
it's starting to learn and starting to
to grab uh
the um the loss and iterating here and
so that is
alpha zero doing its thing on the cloud
now that's just half the story right
getting
code up and running in the cloud is
great and all but you really want to
introspect the results and see what's
going to happen so let's switch over to
vs code of course right
and while sebastian's been working on
all of the things
there he's also been working on an
interconnect to julia hub where we can
download the results
from a uh from uh
run from there you can see the job list
and i'm just gonna untar these results
uh into my local namespace here and
alphazero has built into it some really
cool tools for learning and
introspection so we can go to the file
browser
pick out some of the plots that it
generates
there's lots of depth here and lots of
ways of exploring how alpha zero does
its thing
encourage you to check that out let's
just look at the benchmark
of what percentage of wins do
okay this was basically what i wanted to
show right so
you're able to you know run this uh you
know this computation at scale
on on a combination of cpus gpus
in the cloud with just the press of a
single button and
there's a question from the audience
about
uh about how how does uh
how does julius parallel computing work
is it like fortran an mpi run
so the answer is that julia actually has
its own distributed computing
uh apis so if you go to the julia
language documentation
and then you go to the standard library
you will see a
library called distributed
finally
a second
there we go oh what i actually wanted to
pull up was some what was
the manual or on parallel computing okay
there we go
so
so we have um we have parallel computing
apis uh so so there are three parts to
it
there is asynchronous programming which
is like you know
if you're familiar with goal like go
routines or you know core routines which
is uh
you know a fairly well-known concept
then we have multi-threading
and then we have the distributed
computing and distributed computing has
sort of this
remote call a spawn and fetch kind of
api so very much like an rpc
so you have this api and you can also
use mpi.jl so
you know these apis are built into julia
the remote call and fetch
however if you want to use mpi style
things you can just go and type mpi
and you can you can you can use you can
use those as well
okay all right um
[Music]
let's see i think i don't have a whole
lot more left in my presentation there
yeah
yeah i had some results from uh from a
drug simulation at pfizer
and some amazing products that are being
built in the world of pharma
and then yeah i think that was my last
night so i'll just leave it up there
uh thank you uh this definitely was
helpful and um
i think everyone is excited now to use
julia and try it
um we will end up with some questions
from the audience if
anyone is please feel free to ask
in the q a box first we want to know if
julia support web applications
and is there any framework or web
application using julia
for web applications yes there is a
framework called ge.jl
actually let me go back here
so there's a it's
called geni.jl that's a web framework
in julia and there is
actually also a julia call there was a
fantastic um
workshop oops not register i wanted live
schedule
let's see uh how do i find this live
schedule
so there is a whole um yeah building
microservices in julia
and applications in julia so this is the
whole you know if you click on this
youtube link
you will be able to find uh is it's a
whole one-day workshop on how to
build web applications in junior
okay thank you there is another question
from
where do you recommend to start from
someone you first
heard about julia today i would suggest
go to juliacademy.com and get started
here
with the introduction to julia by dr
jane harriman
okay another question from ahmed uh what
about security patches
is there any uh productive ones
uh sorry i'm not sure i fully understand
the question
what about security patches is there any
periodic coins
as i mean security patches you know
whenever there is a security issue we
just sort of applied and fix it and we
have a you know a security process
so for people to report security
issues in julia and and then we have a
process of
you know addressing them and fixing them
i don't know if that answers the
question
okay um
another question is julie compiler
similar to python
it is actually not similar to python
it's actually very different
uh julia is a jit compiler whereas
python
is an interpreter so well i mean
when i say jit it's not actually
technically accurate but julia is
actually a compiler so remember how i
showed you
um you know that you can look at the
the assembly code from a julia program
like that i mean you cannot do this in
python right
you cannot see what what's happening so
julia is a compiler whereas python is an
interpreter
and that is why julia is you know while
it retains the ease of python it is just
so much faster
okay thank you i think that's it uh back
to you hassan
uh okay uh sorry uh i wanna talk to you
a lot about
uh how to introduce juliet to
organizations in academia and
uh industry yeah how to introduce so
in academia it's usually you know the
the usually the
the professor the you know there are two
parts of it right there is the research
angle and then there is the teaching
part of it
and julia is now taught in so many
different classes right so if you go to
juilliardlang.org
you have a lot of teaching material
available in this learn section
so all the classes that teach julia
you can you can see many of them
actually publish their lecture notes
online
and so depending on the nature of the
class you're teaching in julia you may
be able to actually reuse a lot of this
work
um and of course there are also all
these textbooks like i pointed out
um and so you you can also put together
a class using one of these textbooks uh
as well
um in terms of organizations
usually you know the way to introduce
julia is kind of you know the way i'm
doing this right now right so people
should
you you usually need one champion who
will try out
something do a poc demonstrate it to
your colleagues and then sort of go from
there
and one of the things that organizations
want to know is that is there a company
supporting this right because
you know what if i run into an open
source issue or something and there is
no fix
in the community is there a company that
can sort of you know stand behind julia
and actually sort of support a company
when they use it
and the answer is yes so julia computing
is that company we support our customers
commercially
and you know in a variety of different
ways through support and products
so i think that is sort of you know the
combination
of all the technical materials and then
you know the business uh
assurances is what i think you need at a
company
okay thank you very much i have another
question uh
when i try to debug my code uh
when i when i do it usually in other
languages like
bison or java i can't just write the
question
in the search engine and i will find an
answer
in julia i noticed that the community is
not that
big yet so how to
overcome this issue yeah so you know the
stack overflow in julia is getting a
whole lot better right it's uh it's you
know it has grown
dramatically over the years but a lot of
the reasons why people don't
find the answers on stack overflow is
because the answers usually exist on
discourse on the julia discourse so if
you come here
if you look at the julia discourse i
mean there are almost 10 000 people
who are subscribed to this discourse you
know system here
and usually people who have questions
about julia they usually find the
answers right here
and i would suggest checking the julia
discourse as well as online but
at the end of the day julia is a
relatively newer community compared to
python and r so you will not find
the answers as easily and as often as
you might
in other systems but i would say that
join
the julia language you know discourse
and by the way i should also suggest
joining the julia language slack i can
demonstrate it right here uh this the
slack has a help desk channel where it's
very easy for you to get answers
and help from people so here's your
julia language slack
and you know if i go to the general
channel here
there are you know there are 7 000
people
that are on this slack channel i mean
it's huge so
um and and also remember if you find a
question that is not answered
i'll ask the question on stack overflow
someone will eventually get around
answering it
okay thank you very much so this is the
end of the
meetup um thank you vera who has an
interesting meet up
thank you our audience for joining we
hope to see you in our next events
and yeah thank you for inviting me yes
mean
uh julia join the community all right
bye
we will we will thank you so much
bye-bye